so I'm going to give just a little bit
of background on myself and the team and
kind of where this stuff is coming from
and then what I'm going to do is take
you through a very nuts and bolts
presentation on just absolute features
that we've released that you guys could
start taking advantage of tomorrow to
help grow your audiences using different
Google features and technologies across
all Google properties so first a little
bit of where this is coming from so the
background story on the Google+ platform
team is that a really big chunk of that
team actually came in when google
acquired a company called me Bo that I
was a co-founder of and when we were
doing meebo we went for like you know
seven years and we're doing a lot of
really fun technology actually just so
you guys can see it raise your hand if
you're in this room and you're a part of
the meebo acquisition so in this room
alone we've got probably like seven
people from meebo so as part of meebo
we'd talk to google a bunch and we'd say
hey google like they're these features
that we really want you to do and of
course selfishly is an entrepreneur I
wanted Google to do it because it would
help me Bo grow its audience and I could
never really convinced Google to do it
when I was meebo but then vivo went and
got acquired by Google and I got on the
inside and I want everybody here and I
said hey like there are these features I
always wanted you guys to do why didn't
you do them and you know the answer that
came back was basically oh well we've
never had you know that team to do them
and we didn't have someone who kind of
had the vision for those kinds of
features but if you guys want to start
making those things happen then go ahead
and start you know building those
features and so a lot of the features
that you're going to see today we're
literally produced by an entrepreneur
startup team that came into Google
specifically for what we wanted when we
were entrepreneurs and start you know
start up in your guys seats right so
that's where a lot of this is coming
from it's literally hey you know if
you're doing a start-up if you're trying
to grow an audience what could Google do
to really help you and so that's really
the the basis for where a lot of the
comes from with that let me just jump
into some of this some of these features
here so you know Vic just did a pretty
good job I think of giving you guys kind
of the Google+ overview but you know if
I were to just summarize what Victor
said to you right Google+ is very much
about giving you a relevant experience
across all of Google right and you just
heard that kind of loud and clear I
think that's a really important thing to
grok about Google+ that you know frankly
before I got to Google I didn't
completely understand right Google+ is
really can we give you a better
experience on your Android device or can
we give you a better experience in
search or in maps because we know more
about you we know more about your
friends and we can therefore give you a
much better experience right and like
Vic was just saying the way that Google+
was built was to both help Google create
a better experience for its users at its
properties but then also to help the
rest of the internet create a better
experience for its users at its
properties right and of course a really
big thing for I assume all of you is
certainly a really big thing for me
though was can we help you grow right at
the end of the day a huge thing for
everybody sitting in the room is how
much are we helping grow your audience
and so when we thought it sat down and
kind of said look what are the three big
goals that we want to help developers
achieve it really came down to you know
grow the number of absolute uniques
right because that's a really big deal
at the end of the day we're always
looking at kind of the top line like how
many uniques do we have coming into the
system right on a you know daily weekly
monthly basis you know when we were
meebo we like to look at our monthly
numbers because they're a little bit
bigger Google's big enough that we can
look at our daily numbers and those look
pretty good too at Google can we help
you deepen engagement right so top-line
growth is great in all but if you don't
have users coming back regularly then
obviously the top-line growth just kind
of flames out and it was kind of like
burning newspaper everybody's sitting
here you guys all know that viscerally
so we said hey we really want to help
people deep an engagement of their
existing users
and then you know obviously these days
mobile is becoming kind of the de facto
standard right you think about mobile
first you know in my team we instituted
a rule really early on that all product
mocks that came forward when we were
thinking about new features had to be
mobile knocks first like you could not
bring desktop mocks forward and then if
you wanted to talk about desktop that's
great but they had to sit behind a
mobile mock and that's how important
Mobile's become right i mean you know
most publishers i talked to at this
point the traffic is at least thirty
percent from mobile if not 60-plus
percent so we said hey what can we do to
help people drive Android installs how
can we really focus on mobile and create
a much better experience not just on the
mobile device itself but connecting
mobile devices to the web and trying to
make something really seamless there so
you'll see a lot of that in the features
I'm going to go through so that's the
lead in and with that I'm now going to
just dive into straight features that
hopefully help you guys figure out what
you could do to help grow your audiences
with some Google technology so the first
one this one's really awesome how many
people here run some kind of business or
part of some kind of business that could
have a you know presence on the internet
raise your hand okay good how many of
you have a Google+ page raise your hand
if you have an active Google+ page okay
about fifty percent so early on on we
did a feature which said hey in Google
search search is always looking for
fresh relevant content to show users who
are doing searches in fact one of the
things we learn in Google search is that
fresh content gets clicked on much more
regularly than stell content which is
not surprising right you guys do an
update to your app you always see that
little uptick and growth right the
second you do an update and so we said
one of the things we said is hey where
can we get fresh
10 if someone searches for your property
so let's say you're from soundcloud and
someone doesn't search from South out or
GQ magazine and someone says hey I'm
looking for a GQ magazine they type GQ
magazine out up in the search bar well
an obvious place to get fresh content is
from your google plus page and so what
we've done is if you have an active
Google+ page right has to be active
because the content has to be fresh then
on the right-hand side of the search
results where you'd normally see ads
instead you see a little bit of
information about you know in this case
GQ and you see the most recent posts
that they've made on their Plus page
right so this is if you think about it
this is one of the best ways to kind of
help people searching for your property
see the content that you would want them
to see because if you've recently posted
it on your Plus page and someone does a
search for your brand on google that
content is extremely likely to appear in
the right hand side of search yeah this
is a desktop feature for now
uh does that one make sense yeah and by
the way I'm happy to do this iteratively
with questions as I go yep yes the most
recent post and I get the question a lot
to head this one off if I start today
will I see it in an hour it won't it
won't be an hour like a lot of things
with Google the answer is the machines
figure it out but just begin posting
regularly and check back on the search
for your brand and you'll see it
happened reasonably quickly any other
questions on this one before I go on
this is like the no-brainer of this
conversation active+ page equals you
know a little bit of help with search
yeah fire this is when someone's
directly searching for you okay last
question on this one yep fire
I'm going to talk about mobile apps and
search in a second oh sorry the question
was well this since I think your
question was will this install and bolt
your mobile app if you are a mobile app
yep so I'm going to I'm going to go
through a little bit of searching mobile
apps in a second all right I'm going to
move on to the next feature I hope you
guys grok this one and it was helpful so
next one let's talk about search and
mobile apps so we just announced this I
think was it yesterday good today Wow so
today this was announced by a search
team so when a relevant search is made
where you would come up in that search
result we are now enabling deep links
into your app when they are on that
users phone right so in this case when
the search comes back up someone does a
search for like you know James Stewart
holiday movie and there was an IMDB
result that made sense for that user
there is now a deep link to IMDB to that
result inside that app because that user
did that search right so this is the
first time we're deep linking from
search straight into the right place
inside your mobile app this is obviously
should be very very powerful to drive
growth for you guys it shows up if
you're on the phone we're looking for
the app that the users most likely to
use based on what they've got on their
device and so then figuring out hey you
know IMDb we're going to deep link in
there yeah so question is didn't then
this wasn't there always a way to
register a handler so there were ways in
the past to register a handler someone
could Vic prezelle probably could give
the a deeper answer to this but there
were ways to register a handler for
search this is getting those results
much more prominently in to the mobile
search in in getting that deep Lincoln
for you
exactly the other piece to this release
that we just announced is in addition to
deep linking for certain searches we're
now also having kind of the right apps
that might make sense for a given search
up here and letting you know that you
can go ahead and download those apps
from the search result results they will
send you into Google Play to let a user
find your app and install your app and
then there is a URL don't for each one
of these you'll see your URL at the
bottom that'll help you figure out
exactly where to go to learn more so
this one is a slapdash indexing all
right next next set of features I'm
going to run through so um this one is
one of my absolute favorites to do what
you wanted which is Drive Android app
installs um we found a lot of users
didn't even know that web properties had
an associated mobile app it's like I go
to you know ESPN com all the time and I
just didn't even know that there was an
Android app available for espn.com and
so we wanted to find a way to make it
super simple for users to discover that
app particularly if they're already a
fan of a given property so we built and
this is an example of Fitbit doing it is
if a user connects or signs into that
property using google plus we now know
that that user is a fan of that website
right do it on fitbit com do it on you
know I me know soundcloud com tune in
etc and when the user logs in they get
the normal off dialogue that says hey
you're going to connect you know make a
connection between Fitbit and Google are
you okay with that and if that user has
an android device could be a tablet
could be a phone doesn't matter if it's
on their person right they could have
forgotten at home it could be in their
pocket in their desk drawer will know
and then we'll bring up another dialog
it
hey when you also like to install Fitbit
on your android device if they have
multiple devices we just put up a little
menu that says hey you know which device
would you like to put this on and when
the user clicks install that application
is now directly installed onto the
device in hits their home screen the
user never touched their mobile device
right they just found you on the web
somewhere and they chose to make a
connection between Google and your
property and because we did that we
assume the person is a fan of you and so
would probably want your want your
mobile app and so we're now giving them
the option to get your mobile app this
is probably the most seamless way
possible to drive installs of your
Android app right the only users who
will see this our users who have an
Android device right so if they don't
have an Android device we will not show
them the screen and if they already have
your app we won't show them the screen
of course but if there's someone with an
android device who doesn't yet have your
app will ask them do you want it and if
they say yes users you know it'll be on
the device now we often get the question
hey this is great how many users
actually say yes and on average forty
percent of people who get asked hey do
you want the app say yes for Fitbit it's
been sixty percent and I've seen it go
as low as about twenty-five percent so
you know some some sites are doing
better than others but all of those
percentages are massively massively
better than the conversion that you get
on ads that you're buying to drive
installs of your mobile app so this is
an awesome way to drive Android installs
yep you've had a question for a while so
yeah this is a user signs in using
google on your website because they
signed in using google we now know who
that person is on google we know that
you both use google you like you're this
person on google and you're this person
on on on this website people are logged
into their android
the OS level so if you have an Android
device we know that you have that device
and we then say on the website hey do
you want the Android app and if you say
yes the Android app just appears on your
phone the next time you pick it up
you're only gonna get prompted once yep
and that's the prompt that has the forty
percent accept rate on average and fire
good question so the question was if
your brand has multiple apps how do you
wait those and can you display several
so right now we only support downloading
one app unfortunately the request for
multiple apps we've gotten from large
brands we haven't yet figured out a way
to make that work so right now we've
recommended to brands is use you use the
app that is most associated with the
given property so someone's on like ESPN
in its SportsCenter then give them the
Sports Center at right versus you know
if it's some other your properties and
give them that up yep back of the room
the question was from which OS version
is compatible and I think it's Froyo or
gingerbread which one froyo and above so
basically all basically 90 plus percent
of android devices this will work for
one last question on this one then I'm
going to move on the next feature yup
fire does it work for whites are is it
working paid apps good question not not
right now all right with this one I'm
going to move on so net if you want to
drive Android installs this is a really
really good way to do it right all the
users who go to your website if they
have an Android device this is the best
way to get them an Android app by the
way almost all the features that I'm
going to touch on today work for any web
browser work for Android and work for
iOS this is the one feature that we
cannot do on iOS unfortunately I wish we
could but this one we can only do an
Android ok so next thing we've now
figured out a way to get your users to
have very likely have your Android app
and your users both using on the web
right they use you on Android they might
use you on an iPad right
they use you across multiple devices in
fact they probably use you at work and
at home right so a huge problem in
today's world is just cross device
fragmentation right I don't know you
know when we were meebo we were like
which ones are these unique IPS are
actually unique users we know we don't
really know right because you've got
like an IP in one place an IV in a
different place and it might actually be
the same person at working home and so
we're trying to create a way to make
that really seamless to connect a single
user across all devices for you so the
way we've done that is we've a coupla
mented cross-device single sign it what
that means is if a user signs in with
Google+ on to your property on any
device they will now be automatically
signed in across all devices so they
sign in to you on their desktop PC at
work and then they go home if they
navigate to your you know to your app on
their home machine they will
automatically be signed in to your app
on their home machine they don't have to
touch anything it just happened and then
they pick up their android phone and
they you know open up your app they're
automatically connected on your Android
app they didn't have to touch anything
you now know that that user that Amy is
Amy at when she's at work when she's at
home when she's on her Android device or
on her iOS device this is if you think
about the implications for this for
gaming for example it's really great for
saving state right like getting the user
back to the same level that they've been
at for commerce it's amazing right
someone starts filling in a shopping
cart on you know their android device
and abandons and we all know a lot of
people abandon right but then they go
home and they go back to your site and
their shopping cart is already filled up
right because they're automatically
connected they don't have to connect
again so this one's incredibly powerful
add
targeting right you now know you know if
you build an interest profile on some
one on one device you can then take that
interest profile and know that it's the
same person and add target them
appropriately on the other device or
just giving them a more personalized
relevant experience all right so this is
an easily most seamless way to know that
a user is a user across every device
they access you on fire it just it's the
same as oh sorry the repeat the question
was what's the credential valid time so
it's the same thing for google plus sign
and the token doesn't expire are how do
identify so question was how we had
identifying machine to user so all this
Vic actually mentioned it a little bit
he referenced this when he talked early
on so this is piggybacking on the back
of the google sign it so if the user
signed in on that device we know that
that user is that user right and so
we're piggybacking on the we're
basically letting your sign and
piggyback on the Google sign-in to then
no okay this is this user across devices
gmail or Maps or search it as long as
they are signed in in that instance of
that you know either browser or device
then this will work for YouTube because
we're able to go carry that through even
if it's a different app on Android on Io
on iOS if a user signs in on iOS it
carries to every device seamlessly um if
a user navigates to your app on iOS and
they're already connected that's the one
place where we need one tap because we
aren't able to do that cross device we
can't do the cross at immediate
connection we need one tap everywhere
else that's zero any other questions on
this one
hi oh yeah absolutely users can sign out
easily either with your own app or on
the Google side I'm going to move on so
at this point we've gone through really
really easy way to get you know users
information about you on search right by
connecting a plus page then we went into
okay well how can we drive more Android
installs right and then we talked about
how can we have a user across all
devices be a single user to you so that
you know who that person is and can give
them a much better experience so let's
see what we've got next so let's talk a
little bit about sharing you know
obviously a really important thing for
everybody is how do you do just straight
up a new user acquisition right and so
we've built some really powerful sharing
channels that hopefully will help you
guys get new user acquisition if you
watch closely this is actually the first
time that we've opened up the google
notifications channel to developers in
order to be able to message up for user
on your system to google a message their
friends back on google so let's see how
that works so let's say that you prompt
the user to share to Google in some way
alright so when the user enters a share
flow first off you know I'd make sure
that you're taking advantage of all the
various places that you can grab a
user's friends to let them share to
right so one is when a user does a
connection with Google+ right they have
access to all the Google+ friends
there's also the contacts API right from
Android so you can also get the contacts
API and get a list of a user's friends
that way too once you have a list of the
users friends and you prompt the user to
share you are able as a developer to
programmatically send in up to ten
people's friends names in the to field
of a share box from google plus so you
can do that as a developer right so you
could grab
you can even get a rank ordered list of
friends based on affinity from google
plus that's an API call that we support
and then you could show a box it says
hey you know which of your friends do
you want to send this video to and then
once that user chooses up to 10 friends
right and hits ok share will put you
into this google UI and you will
pre-populate up to 10 names in the two
fields right because you want to make it
really really easy for the users to
decide who they're going to send
something to now if you've done that if
there are individuals names in the to
field when the user hits send their
friends will get a message across all
Google properties in the notification
system so that little bar that's in the
upper right on every Google property
right you see it on search maps plus
YouTube there's no place in Google
effectively that does not have the
notification system built in so if I
sent you know in a message that a video
that I wanted to share and I'd put vicks
and Amy's names in that video in that
share then they will have their notifier
light up across Google properties so
this is really the first time that we've
made it easy for you as a developer to
get access to the Google notification
system this is a very very powerful way
that help your users bring their friends
into your app now it's also am going to
stop there and then we'll talk about one
or feature questions on this one before
I go on because this one I know is
nuanced but very powerful yep the
question was is it possible to determine
which one of your friends already use
your app that is not yet available as an
API call you could do it on your side
that would definitely be in the category
of geez we should probably do that so
watch for it seems like a logical next
step yep so the question was I mentioned
that we have an affinity algorithm so we
can return a list of friends based on
affinity what does that look like
unfortunately we don't have a way to
rank it based on kind of affinity by
interest we only have overall affinity
which is basically
you how much does this person
communicate with and abroad google wide
sense this other person so right now
that's going to be kind of a good ranked
list for general affinity but not sliced
by interest um that would be awesome
probably not in the near term all right
I'm going to move on with this one will
take questions at the end too but this
one like I said great way to get a
notification stream now next thing is
when a user gets this you know item that
was shared so in this case you know
check out google streetview conquering
the oceans notice that it's got that
view button down at the bottom right
like a very specific hey that action on
this share is to view or you know here
we've got a share that's coming in i
think from tune in and there's a very
specific call to action here it's listen
right so what we've done is we've
created a type of share that we call an
interactive post that has a really
prominent call to action that really
prominent call to action gets on average
three times the click rate of a normal
share and it's just because it's such a
very clear like signal to the user hey
i'm supposed to you know click to listen
or click to join our click to play right
i think there are 150 verbs that we
support here and we just chose 150
because we wanted to translate them into
every language for you guys if you have
verbs in your mind that we don't have on
the list you know you can feel free to
let us know we can probably add them so
this is a really great way to make sure
that when a user gets the share they
know like hey I'm supposed to click this
to play or two to join or whatever the
action is that you want alright so if i
were to sum this this kind of section up
right we talked about search we talked
about installing android apps and keep
them keeping users connected across
devices this one is hey how can i get my
existing users to invite their friends
across Google right note doesn't matter
where their friends are on Google
they're on Google+ if they're on youtube
if they're on maps search how can i get
my friends across all Google properties
to come and then take action inside your
property and oh by the way from a growth
perspective not only will descend your
users friends to your app if let's say I
receive you know this share from katie
and i don't have tuned in on my device
on both iOS and Android will send Katie
to the app store or to the Play Store so
Katie can get the app and then once
Katie Hatter sorry in this case I get
the app and once I have the app I'll get
deep linked to the right place inside
that app so this can drive app installs
for you as well seamlessly across
platforms alright next one um so we've
taken the same concept and applied it to
email so we recently launched something
called smart mail I think this is still
white list is that right it's still
white list so you'd have to ping who are
going to tell people obtain vick you're
going to ping vick fries el at google
com so you'll ping vic and you can add a
little bit of markup to the emails that
you send people will recognize the
markup and put the same kind of kind of
visual actions into gmail the same way
we're doing it for those shares so it's
really really clear call-to-action like
hey you know meeting of the cafe are you
going yes maybe no and we haven't talked
about kind of what the level of
increased engagement we see when there's
a really clear call to action that's
kind of in the UI on gmail but it's been
pretty staggering so this is just some
really easy mark up again remember for
to get more details on all this there's
the URL on the bottom right there to get
more interaction with your emails that
you're sending people do a little bit of
markup and get a really clear call to
action for users all right so this is
applying the same sharing concept from
kind of the shares across Google to
email and I should have said about the
shares across Google to I just think I
should probably make this
lisset this action when it's shared
inside the notification system on any
property so here it's being shared into
maps notice that the the action appears
right on that share at maps and that
will send the user straight into your
app or straight over to your website
right so we're not kind of moving them
within Google and then over to your site
we're just sending them straight as
traffic to you all right next one this
one's one of my favorites so um how many
of you operate a site that has ugc
user-generated content in your hand so
about a third great so this is
particularly relevant if you operate a
ugc site so if people are creating
content on your site sometimes that
content appears in Google search all
right you know someone authors a blog
post for example on wordpress and that
blog post you know can get picked up by
Google's crawler and end up in search
and we wanted to create a way that make
it more clear where that actually came
from and who authored that content and
so for a while we had this feature
called authorship that lets someone's
like you know picture and link to their
Google+ profile appear in the search
results but we wanted to make it really
really easy and kind of democratize that
feature and make it available for
everyone so now if your users sign in to
your site using google plus we take that
as a signal that they definitely use
your property and when we go find
content inside your property of course
it's public that's crawlable and we put
it into the google search engine it will
now benefit from authorship
automatically so as long as you've
marked up that content with the rel
equals author length so that we know
right we're now trusting you because
we've seen that that user has indeed
used your property because they
connected google to your property and
we're then just automatically applying
authorship to it back at search and that
user's name and a link to the profile
and oftentimes their picture will then
appear
so this is an awesome way to just help
your users and you get more obviously
more visibility on the result inside
search yep go ahead yeah and the
question was in the by automatic what
exactly do I mean yes so in the past
this was pretty difficult to hook up
like a user would have had to what I'd
see people doing we thought of this
because we saw like crazy ways people
were hooking this up where they had some
teaching thing on their site like hi you
using a Vimeo here's the way to link
your Vimeo you know videos I'm google
search to you go to this google plus
page put your name in here when you find
this little button that's hidden we've
gotten rid of all of that now as long as
the users connected google+ to your
property it will just work for that user
as long as you've got the relic cool
authors tag on your pages next one so
i'm going to now enter kind of the broad
section of and i talked about this yet
so going to take a moment to do it when
you do that initial Google+ sign-in when
you make that initial connection between
a user and your property you can ask at
that point for effectively any API that
Google has to offer about that user like
that is the point at which you can say
hey I want access to your calendar or I
want your email address right or I want
to subscribe you to a YouTube channel
there are amazing things that you can
ask that create a really deep link
between the users entire Google
experience and your property and I'm
just going to go through some of those
things that you can ask for now that are
of course growth oriented so one in
calendar when a user clinic makes a
connection to your app if you really do
anything that's time-related ask for
permission to read and write to users
Google Calendar right if they book a you
know travel reservation on your property
like put that booking automatically on
that calendar without that user taking
any action at all that makes a lot of
sense all right so that's one thing that
you can ask for and do
another one that's really neat is you
can get access to store things on that
users Google Drive right so view and
manage Google Drive files that you've
opened or created with this app so if it
users creating content on your property
you could literally automatically store
that into the users Google Drive account
and you just got permission to do that
at the beginning right when a user
connected Google with your property this
one's amazing subscribe to our videos
right so if you have videos if you have
a youtube channel and you want a user to
be subscribed to the videos on your
YouTube channel you can ask for that
permission to when a user signs in this
is a user from you know the permission
appears right there in the normal
Google+ sign-in dialogue and then when
user goes and looks at their
subscriptions in YouTube the
subscription is just there right so you
know I've gone through a bunch of
features that are tied to Google+
sign-in like you know installing an
Android app or keeping your user
connected across devices but really at
that one point you are creating
fundamentally a connection between that
users Google experience across kind of
all Google properties and your own
property and so it's a great time to ask
for things like calendar access or like
a YouTube subscription and you can even
ask for recommendations right so YouTube
has an API where you can ask for
recommendations for a given user all
right like what videos would this person
like and we've seen people use that as a
recommendations engine right so this is
what we believe that particular user
would like and then you can use that of
course the tune your own recommendations
to so the last one in this category that
I want to spend a moment on is asking
for wallet permission so when a user
signs in with google to your property if
you want the user to buy anything from
you we've seen amazing results with
people asking for permission to use
wallet for purchasing and then that
becomes a
really simple action for the user once
they land on your checkout screen it's
like tap and you're done and that's
incredibly powerful we've seen like I
said incredible results I think we have
wanted to share it in the end here so if
we're going to sum up kind of some of
the success stories that we've seen with
partners because you know I'm sure you
guys are wondering hey how does all this
stuff perform so I've already talked
about Fitbit where they're seeing a
sixty percent except rate on the Android
app installs which is pretty awesome you
know overall flixster said hey
thirty-five percent of our web traffic
and forty five percent of Android users
are choosing to sign in with Google+ one
of the most interesting things that I
found in all this so we launched the
Google+ sign-in notion about eight or
nine months ago right so the meebo team
got here like I said it took us a few
months to get it out then we got it out
and I'll tell you a story about
something that I completely screwed up
so when we got here my theory was
sign-in by itself was completely
irrelevant and didn't matter right it
was like great we have a google sign an
option that doesn't matter what matters
are the features that we put behind it
like you know a user signs in and you
now have access to their calendar or a
user signs in and now we can help you
drive an Android install so my theory
was it was all about the features and
not at all about signing and then we
launched it and it turned out I was
completely wrong it turned out that just
having a Google sign-in option next to
whatever else you use twitter facebook
native literally lifts the percentage of
users who choose to sign into your app
that one to me was shocking I didn't see
that one coming all right but literally
just lifting the absolute number of
users who choose to register with you
and in retrospect it's obvious right it
turns out that you know native is kind
of a pain right people fear spam from
like Facebook right it's like okay if I
sign in then I'm going to spam my
friends and people don't have that fear
around Google right they trust Google
and so you'll notice a lot of the
features that we've talked about like
driving an Android install or keeping
user connected across devices all of
that is a user election even the stuff
around getting into the notification
stream on google which we've now opened
up right that's user election right the
users choosing to do a share so we're
not doing kind of auto share so we're
keeping users in a really comfortable
place and giving users control but at
the same time it all helps you guys
drive growth so you know pics have said
to that point I'm driving increased
registration that they literally saw a
twenty-one percent increase in
registration by virtue of adding the
Google option which really surprised me
and then the final one higher order
value so a fancy literally saw that on
average a user who signed in with google
and had that wallet permission there
right on average their order value is
fourteen percent higher and that's
amazing right and it's just because
making that connection between in this
case wallet and fancy right by doing
that Google sign-in made shopping easier
and not to mention this is really
interesting it came back from them they
believe a big part of that as well as
actually the cross device single sign on
as well people like I said people
creating a shopping cart on one device
right and then abandoning but then later
accessing fancy on another device
there's shopping carts already there
maybe they choose to add something else
to it and then they go ahead and hit
purchase alright so that's the kind of
bulk of what I wanted to go through I
hope it was helpful I'm definitely gonna
take questions for a little bit but if I
just were to sum all this up right at
the end of the day the first thing we
talked about right if you have an active
Plus page your most recent post appears
on the right hand side of Google search
this is the easiest way to help your
users find content about you when they
search for you on google right and to
make sure they're finding content that
youth you think would be interesting for
them
right driving Android installs if a user
connects with you on the web make it
unbelievably easy for them to just hit
one button on the web and download an
app onto their device keeping that user
connected across all devices right once
they've connected in one device are
connected on all devices awesome for
things like you know shopping carts ad
targeting more relevant user experiences
right knowing your statistics better and
then you know Google sign-in a core we
went through a lot of features that you
can ask for right permissions like
calendar or drive or wallet when a user
does of Google's you know kind of
connects Google is they're connecting
all of google to your app and as long as
you've asked for that permission right
you will get by default the user's name
and the users profile picture and their
list of friends but you can ask for more
you can ask for their email address you
can ask for permission to see their
calendar and to write to their calendar
so think about which permissions you
would want and ask for those so you can
create a much richer experience for that
user on your property